good morning John
[Music]
all righty we are headed to the
convention center backstage at VidCon
still this year is a little bit more
tips at lose like almost three times
larger than last year right every time
I'm excited they just kind of hop look
up I really like to make people hear my
videos it's our favorite favorite show
to play I'm having the best time I've
had if you love YouTube personalities or
you can show definitely this is a con to
make time alright first it was like oh
well you start going to Wow you're like
I can't imagine like a better community
of people to be around you just had an
article in Forbes on what boss baller
[Music]
I wish to do this against you know with
more one more damn Victor let's just do
it
let's do it Samuel maybe Nick next year
next year I was in LA this week for like
36 hours it was freaking nuts mostly
planning for VidCon I'm at the bottom of
the universe a talent agency right now
not because I'm Talent it's a VidCon
thing the wallpaper is needed and
there's scope so that everybody's breath
can smell fresh when they have their
meetings and I got to hang out the new
YouTube creator space which is so crazy
that I think that it may be literally
insane and I got to hang out and fill
the my drunk kitchen with Hannah Hart
and mamrie Hart who are not related and
also daily grace Helbig was there those
of you who don't know what VidCon is
it's a gathering that Jon and I started
every year for people who love online
video whether you do it professionally
or it's a hobby or you just really like
it the creators and the communities and
also the people who enable it like the
ad sales people YouTube employees and
people who run networks and all that all
of it ah it's an all-ages show though
you should note that the state of
California doesn't let you check into a
hotel if you're under 18 so plan for
that we have two tracks as we always
have there's the very expensive industry
track for people who do this for a
living in order to subsidize the
community track which still is pretty
expensive because throwing something
like this is very expensive the
community track tickets are $100 right
now anyway the price goes up as the
conference gets closer quick example of
the difference between the community
track in the industry track writ but
really a panel about how to use a green
screen or a session on the intricacies
of the jump cut that would be community
track whereas a talk on the
disadvantages and advantages of
consolidation of channels into
multi-channel networks that would be an
industry talk hopefully that clears
things up stuff about how to make better
videos that doesn't go in the industry
track so there's a specific industry day
on Thursday August first and then the
second and third is when the conference
opens up to everyone and then on the
fourth we have Disney day where online
video takes over Disney pretty much we
got a listing of who so far is confirmed
coming to the conference but of course
that list is going to get longer as for
what goes on at VidCon lots of things go
on signings and meetups and QAS and
discussions and talks and concerts and
performances and there's a vol page what
has been previously I'm not 100% of the
ball pit yet
planning is going very well we've
already sold like a third of the ticket
so that's crazy and for people who can't
get to Anaheim don't worry it's not the
end of the world if you don't get to
come to VidCon and maybe there will be
gatherings that will be coming to your
neck of the world sometime soon
especially if your neck of the world is
in the United Kingdom that's all I can
say right now there's a frequently asked
questions page at VidCon complet is also
where you can buy tickets and find out
more about the conference generally John
I'll see you on Tuesday